what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on super-pumped
to be talking about rebooting AI we have
dr. Gary Marcus joining us on the show
hi Gary
great to be here thank you so much for
coming on the show really appreciate it
thank you so pumped for this it's been a
long time in the making almost three
years of aiming to make something like
this happen our conversation and it's
good timing because he has just
published rebooting AI building AI that
we can trust for those that don't know
Gary's background he's a scientist
best-selling author and entrepreneur
founder and CEO of robust AI which is
building a new foundation for the future
of robotics was founder and CEO of
geometric intelligence an ml company
acquired by uber in 2016 and is the
author of five books most recently
rebooting AI which is about building
computer systems with the conceptual
framework of our world time-space
causality so we can trust them and not
fear their operation you can find all
gary's links below Gary Marcus comm
robust a IDE robust dot a eye as well as
his Twitter LinkedIn profiles in the
newest book rebooting AI Gary I love how
you take things from this perspective of
we are birthed into the world and we
start building a conceptual framework
and the same style of how a child begins
building conceptual framework if we can
start helping our computer systems have
a conceptual framework that's somewhat
similar to that at least can be a much
more robust AI that we can trust is this
about
exactly right and I mean it goes back to
Plato and Khan's talking about innate
ideas so there's a long kind of
distinction nature versus nurture I
think anybody who's ever seriously study
the problem realizes it's both nature
and nurture if you're talking about
biology so we have genes built-in that
help build rough drafts of our brains
well I wrote another book about that and
some time ago called the birth of the
mind it's pretty clear that that's how
biology works we don't know all the
details but it's clear we're not born
blank slates politically people might
wish that we were but we're not
and nor were we born with every you know
detail of our brain complete right we
learn a lot if you look at machine
learning though in AI it's really moved
to one side of that spectrum which is
the nurture side of the spectrum so
people are trying to learn everything
from raw unanalyzed data so like how do
you play Atari games you feed in pixels
and joystick motions and make a machine
figure everything out without any
conception of what a brick is or what
gravity is or or the goal of a game or
anything like that and you get results
that's sort of liquid but they're really
just approximations they don't really
work when you change things so if you're
playing breakout and you move the paddle
three pixels all thing breaks down so
what I'm saying is we need some nature
along with the nurture we need to keep
using clever ideas about machine
learning but we have to bring in some of
what biology has which is good starting
points like for example the cons in the
critique of pure reason talked about
space and time and causality is critical
I think they're critical for machines to
we're trying to build machines without
that hoping for the best from vast
droves of big data it's just not gonna
work I like the way that you frame it as
this biological starting point a nature
and what would you say would be that
ideal framework to start things off with
I mean I would start by saying we don't
we're not trying to build replicas of
human beings here right I mean I have
two children and that's you know they're
they're they're miniature humans with
with you know human brains and we're not
in in the lab trying to do the same
thing as biology but I would say that
there are some things biology does
really well in some really poorly so I
wrote a whole book another book about
all the things that the human mind does
that are kind of substandard so our
memory systems for example are lousy and
in my book Cluj I talk about how it is
that we could have evolved things that
aren't optimal they're very associative
but we have poor recall for the vast log
of experience that we've had and we
don't have buffers for example where the
last place I put my keys which trivial
to program in a computer where did I put
my car you go out into a lot the park
every day and you're like I don't
you just you have conflation between all
the different memories you don't have
what a computer has which is called
garbage collection right so and and
location addressable memory so things
are like like first day of computer
science some of them are not built into
the brain so like our brains are not
perfect we don't want to copy them we
don't want to do arithmetic like people
do like hmm did I remember to carry the
one I can't remember like I mean we
don't want that but there are things
that human brains are really really good
at in particular reasoning flexibly and
understanding natural language and those
go hand-in-hand
so if somebody's sitting here
understanding this conversation they're
connecting with things that they might
have heard about before in linguistics
or psychology or yeah and they're very
rapidly as we speak
building up ideas about what we're
talking about and then they can flexibly
use that information so they could use
it to decide whether they're gonna
believe the next news story they hear
about AI or they'll bring it into a
conversation with their friends or maybe
make decisions about how to use it in
their business so people are really
flexible with the information that we
use and we can talk about it in very
flexible ways machines can't do that
there's no AI system that can read a
book like mine and come away explaining
the main ideas or say you know why the
examples were used the way they do
anything you'd expect of a sophisticated
reader so there are things that seem
humans can do much better than machines
and vice versa
ultimately the synthesis is gonna be
some of both so you want you know the
ultimate like Star Trek computer should
understand language as well as a person
but be able to read through vast you
know tables in order to synthesize a new
answer in a way that no human could do
hmm okay so a starting point that takes
some of the best principles of
computational capacities as well as
human biological capacity that's right
and I didn't curse to me I didn't bully
if it answer your first question let me
come back to it
what are those starting point so one
starting point I gave you is kind of
conceptual which is you know you want to
take the best of humans and the best of
computation another starting point is
how do humans understand the world and I
would say it starts by having a
framework and that framework has some
things in it like we know that there are
objects
as objects continue to exist in space
and time there was some confusion I
think from Piaget about that but my best
reading the developmental psychology
literature is kids know that from the
beginning and then you learn about the
specific objects that are in the world
you know that there are psychological
agents you don't know everything about
them but you realize very early in life
that another biological creature is
different from a chair right you can
have a conversation with a person you
can't have a conversation with a chair
and you learn lots of details like what
chairs are like and what people are like
but you start with a framework where you
can learn information about particular
individuals for example so we know that
it's not just that there's Alan Ness in
the world but that Alan is a particular
person and it kind of travels on a space
time continuum he's only at one point at
one time they're not gonna be for Alan's
at the same oh we learn all of this
stuff but we have this basis of what
objects are what people are and then we
learn more information about that as
opposed to if you could just imagine you
just have light on your eyeballs and it
dances around then like the world would
be as William James had a blooming
buzzing confusion what allows us to
learn about the world is that we know
enough from the beginning to structure
the kind of information that we get in
the machines we're building right now
don't have that basic structure except
in some very limited ways and I think
they suffer for it so like you can talk
to the GP t2 system that's very popular
open AI released and it will produce
coherent sounding sentences like they
though or I should say grammatical
sentence or the fluent sounding but
there's no idea what it's actually
talking about if you make it talk for a
little while it will constantly
contradict itself it doesn't really
understand the premises of what it's
saying and so what you get are the like
the correlations it knows which nouns
and verbs follow each other in which
context but it knows nothing about the
thing that it's actually talking about
because there is no conception of space
or time or objects or people all these
basic things that I think are part of
humans and not just humans I mean think
about the baby ibex it climbs down on
the side of a mountain a couple hours
after it's born it has a basic
understanding of three-dimensional
geometry and things like that it's not
conscious but it is evolved to do that
we need AI systems if they're going to
work
a similarly strong starting point rather
than just being blank slates doesn't
mean we toss away learning but you don't
learn much if you don't have a strong
starting point what would you say would
be the let's go back back back and then
we'll try and build up as in what would
be the first sort of framework that a
child is born into the world with you
took an innate ISM stance versus the
blank slate stance and what are then
those fundamental frameworks that a
child is born into the world we don't
know for sure I mean you know you can do
different kinds of experiments to get at
it so you can look at babies and see how
they respond to things I did an
experiment in 1999 in science that's
been replicated that showed that babies
at the age of seven months old a
recognizing kind of abstract pattern so
we gave them sentences like lotta Tigana
nah they were able to recognize whether
other things followed the same patterns
and then other people show that even
newborns could do the same thing and so
that set of experiments for example
shows that babies are looking for rules
and patterns that's one of the most
basic things we're doing and a lot of
current neural networks aren't looking
for rules in the same sense that's just
one example there are other sets of
experiments that show that babies seem
to understand something about causality
very early in life they understand that
you know one billiard ball strikes
another that the second one is likely to
move so that's kind of routes of
causality babies at least pretty early
in life seem to understand something
about objects and they're not I didn't
even if they look identical they're not
identical so they can do something that
looks least looks a little bit like
arithmetic I don't think it's literally
that but early in life there's some
calculus of objects and what they do
that's another thing that is is
presumably they're very early in life
and I'll just pause to say that innate
does not actually literally mean at
birth so like my ability to grow a beard
was built into my biology but it didn't
merge until I was you know 14 or
whatever years old so innate and early
aren't the same but when we see
something very early as early as we can
test in newborns or infants then we tend
to think that it's probably built in
it's it's hard
perfectly prove these things to the best
studies that we could do from a
scientific perspective or not the best
we could do from an ethical perspective
so we really to really answer some of
these questions you would have to do
what we call deprivation studies so what
or you know you raise a child on if you
want to know what kids know about
gravity you raise a child on a space
station and see what happens there's
none but we can't ethically just like
assign you know kids to different
conditions in those experiments so some
things remain unknown but the best gases
from my own work and work from people
like Elizabeth's Pelkey and Renee Baier
Jean and so forth is that kids have some
conception of the world to get started
the centers around things like space
time object causality personhood or
agent to it and so forth and that could
even likely be from the parents the
parent tell experiences and their
parents and their parents just as
transgenerational I think it's
transcendent generational but I think
it's genetically transmitted I mean I
think there's a lot of information that
is transmitted by teaching and by
imitation and just by observing parents
but some of it the most basic
foundations I think are part of the
mammalian brain plan and or even the
vertebrate brain plan and so had a long
history of evolving to see things up
fire and language and the basic ways
that we go and get food and that we love
each other and these types of things
have converse yeah I mean language
itself is complicated case and we could
come back to it but I would say that you
know for a billion years evolution has
been involving creatures that have some
basic comprehension of their world and
understand about obstacles and objects
and predators and prey and you know you
look at the so-called precocial animals
like the ibex that are born and
basically able to walk and it's clear
that genes can do that there's still
calibration so you still have to figure
out how strong are my legs and like the
vervet monkey for example is born with
three calls which basically amount to
aerial predator land predator and so on
and they have to learn exactly what
those look like they have to learn what
an Eagles like what they are born
essentially knowing that there are
things up in the air that you need to
worry about and that you should do a
sort of particular call if you see them
yeah
yes now then how let's move to that next
step then which is okay what about then
the conceptual frameworks for building
artificial intelligence that we can
trust that we don't need to fear how do
we embed time-space coded causality into
computers don't really exist yet I think
that right now and people have thought
about it some but I think that for the
last seven years people have spent
almost all of their effort on systems
that don't have a lot of conceptual
framework that are really good at
picking up on statistics and they've
been very fruitful for things like
speech recognition so speech recognition
you can hear a bunch of syllables and
you can correlate the auditory stream
that you hear with labels for what
what's going on and so the dominant
paradigm for the last seven years is
really about labeling so you see a
picture of a dog and you tell the
Machine this should be a dog you see a
picture of a chair you tell the Machine
that this should be a chair and the
technique that people are using is
pretty good for that so if you show it
another chair there's a good chance if
it's not too different from the other
chairs that seem before that it will
recognize the chair or recognize the dog
if it's not too different for the dog
that's seen before it doesn't mean the
system has a slightest clue what a chair
is for it doesn't mean that the system
understands that some chairs you know
have cushions and others don't and
that's that some are made of wood and
some are not it doesn't mean that the
machine understands anything about the
properties of those objects but we built
these systems are really good at
categorizing and people got really
excited about it and there's some very
nice commercial applications the most
life-changing one might be speech
recognition but it's really great to
have automatic photo tagging is another
example yeah
and so people have gotten kind of
obsessed with a tool that they have you
know the famous saying is to a man with
a hammer everything is a nail there's a
lot of hammer and nail lightest right
now and so I think people are working
really hard to make their hammers just a
little bit more efficient and how can we
you know make the the metal of the
hammer or strike a little bit better and
stuff like that you say something along
the lines of that machine learning is
critical for building robust AI and deep
learning is pretty good for machine
learning and with deep learning we're
doing these things with big data with
statistical models with convolutional
neural
that works this is kind of this paradigm
for image recognition for a and it's
great stuff like it's really genuinely
useful I don't want to say that it's not
but it's like this hammer and nail thing
so it's really great for the problem of
categorizing things and if you have
labeled examples of things you want to
categorize it's great it's not great for
reasoning and it's not great for
language so system is built on this and
they can pick up all kinds of subtle
statistical detail but at the end of the
day they don't really understand the
things that they're talking about it's
just not the right tool for that so the
brain has you know many different brain
regions that do different things we
don't know everything about it but you
know we know the occipital cortex in
Broca's area are doing really different
things and deep learning is kind of like
the occipital cortex it's there for some
part of vision it's really not doing
anything like what we think Broca's area
is doing where you take a sentence and
you break it down into its parts and
then you understand the meaning by
putting together those parts deep
learning doesn't really do that doesn't
do what Broca's area that does it
doesn't do what prefrontal areas do in
terms of and in making rational
calculations about complex ideas it just
doesn't do that and so it's like it
would be is it I mean it's almost also
like a blind man and the elephant it's
like you know people have discovered a
trunk and they think that that it's the
whole elephant and it's not it's a piece
of it I wonder what then would be beyond
just the trunk which is this deep
learning passion that we have for image
recognition natural language what would
be a interesting way for you to
hypothesize the construction of computer
systems that have understandings of
conceptional time space the first thing
I think that the field needs to do is
they get past the kind of holy war that
has gone on for 60-some years which is
between two approaches one is the
approach from which deep learning
emerged which tries to find things
people call them neural networks there
are begley like brains
but there's fundamentally there's
statistical approximator that look at a
lot of data that's one tradition and it
goes
to the 50s and arguably the 40s and then
there's this other approach which is
mystical approximator for big data was
the first yeah I mean originally was
even with little data and now it works
because it has big data if you have
small amounts of data your statistical
approximations aren't that good but so
there were people have been taking one
approach which is basically about
statistical approximation and machine
learning is is kind of a part of that I
mean being a little bit sloppy here and
then there's another approach which has
really been about knowledge and that
comes from the tradition of like
Bertrand Russell and Gottlieb Fraga and
so forth which is about representing
things in formal languages or things
close to that and computer programming
comes from that tradition and it works
great so if you want a web browser you
don't want a machine learn how the web
browser works by giving labeled examples
of people clicking at pages and what
images they show you want to write
software for that in traditional
sentence you want to have if thenns if
the user presses this key then do this
thing load the contents of this buffer
come copy it over to this other buffer
and so there's a whole approach of AI
that is built around what we call symbol
manipulation which looks a lot like
traditional computer program for it you
know many people in your audience
we've done that and the two approaches
have not liked each other for a very
long time they've each one to say do it
our way or the highway and the modern
representative of the do it our way or
the highway on the machine learning side
is geoff hinton
who has gone around saying basically
simple manipulation is like gasoline
engines and deep learning is like
electric engines stop using the civil
manipulation stuff you know it's
antiquated and you should just use my
electric power I mean very hostile to
symbol manipulation and the reality is
we need both reality is his metaphor is
not really right it's not really like a
choice between gasoline engines and
electric engines it's really like we
have different techniques it's more like
we need power screwdrivers hammers nails
we need all kinds of different
techniques because the fundamental
problem we're trying to solve is itself
what a psychologist would call
multi-dimensional there are many
different aspects of intelligence and
it's absurd to expect one silver bullet
and I know he's enamored of
Silver Bullet of you know this kind of
machine learning from raw statistical
data but the reality is that what you do
as a thinking creature ranges from
recognizing patterns you've seen before
at a kind of concrete perceptual level
which deep learning is good for to
making inferences about complex ideas
that you've only just been exposed to
and say does this fit with these other
ideas and and deep learning is just not
a good tool for that and simple
manipulation is a better way to
represent for example things that are
compositional you put the parts together
to make larger and larger parts so we
say the book on the couch and then we
say the book that's on the couch that's
in the room and the book that's on the
couch that's in the room that's in the
house that's in this particular suburb
of California and so forth and you can
understand how all the parts fit
together you know the cat that chased
the rat that chased the mouse whatever
we can build more and more complicated
ideas and that's part of what
civilization is based on we need
different tools for that symbols are
really good tools for that we use them
for example in mathematics that's how we
do physics is you know we put together
symbols that represent abstract ideas
the thought that we're gonna build a I
sort of with a hand tied behind her back
because you know some person who's
famous happens not to work in that
domain is crazy Wow okay and then what
would it be
maybe fair to hear let's hear your
thoughts on this if if we had an ongoing
let's say a clock of all time and we
turned on a computer system and the
first thing it did was calibrate itself
along with this big moving time that's
happening with all of the humans that
know what date it is and that we're
meeting at this time and the computer
systems began also working on that same
idea of time with that then enable them
to talk to each other and talk to other
humans on the same idea of time to start
I would say the first thing you want to
do is just build a variable in your
system which is time or moment or
something like that
so that the machine doesn't have to
induce the very fact that there's time
and I would want to build in some
procedure
some basic things like it should realize
that time flows linearly and you might
want to build in things like people have
birth dates and death dates and they're
not here before they're born in that
here after I build in some basic things
so you can interpret the rest the
alternative is like I don't know you
have a video camera on the world and you
som have to induce the things follow in
temporal sequence and nobody has ever
built a machine that does anything like
that that actually induces from kind of
just raw data that time exists or that
space exists if closest is these neural
networks now building a notion of space
that handles some aspects of space they
build in the notion of what we call
spatial invariance or translational
invariance so if I see my hand here then
I see this image over here they're
probably the same thing is the same
image so convolution is a way of
building that in it's a clever technique
that's built in and then people would
are like I don't want to build anything
else in I do machine learning and they
stress the word learning they don't they
don't want anything else to be built in
but I think it's too hard to induce the
rest anything you know took a long time
to evolve the you know let's say the
mammalian brain but you won't find a
mammal that doesn't understand time
intuitively more or less from the moment
it's born yes right it's not like you
know some you know pygmy marmoset or
something like that
is so smart that it's able to like
extract the the basic temporal nature of
the universe by hanging out like that's
built into the marmosets brain and it's
built into our brains through a long
period of evolution so then would the
would the other functionalities like we
want to see all of these new upcoming
successes with AI helping us with
medical diagnostics we want to see it
succeeding with autonomous vehicles want
to see it succeeding with all different
aspects of making our lives better
and then are we gonna be building
specific narrow a ice for those
applications how do we figure out to
invest time and resources into that
versus this building from this really
first principled framework of time space
and causality how do we say it's a great
question so we didn't quite make
explicit before this distinction that
you just alluded to between narrow AI
and general AI so narrow AI works on a
very specific problem and generally eyes
it doesn't exist yet but the notion is
that it would be able to solve a wide
range of problems and it turns out that
with existing techniques that I would
call narrow AI were able to for example
build machines that play go and chess
extremely well but not to read very well
so nobody's been able to adapt the same
techniques that work can go in chess to
a more open-ended problem like reading
so go you know the rules haven't changed
in two thousand years the board's always
the same size it's a very closed problem
whereas reading is an open-ended problem
you never know what you might see next
so maybe there'll be a cartoon maybe
there'll be a joke about a favorite
television show you have to be able to
kind of roll with the punches and
integrate all kinds of different
information
so that's open-ended and the more
open-ended something is the more it
seems like we need a general approach to
a I then you get that into some of the
specific problems and it's interesting
so like we don't know for sure whether
driverless cars can be built with narrow
AI in a way that's reliable so people
are trying to do that trying to build
driverless cars they don't really have a
conception of what a construction site
is or where the police officer is or
what a highway is but know enough narrow
rules to get by but what we're finding
is that doesn't really work so you have
for example at least five times in the
last 18 months a Tesla has run into a
stopped vehicle on a highway so
emergency vehicles tow trucks fire
trucks police cars right the systems
don't have a conception of what a
stopped vehicle is on the side of the
road and they're not able to cope with
it so it might be empirically that to
really deal with all of the range of
cases like that we need a general
intelligence that is able to reason
about the things that it sees in how the
world
fit together or maybe we'll be lucky and
we don't have to and we can just gather
enough data from enough cases my feeling
is we're not doing that well when we try
to do it without some kind of general
intelligence and that what happens is
there's always some core cases we do
very well and then a periphery around it
where the current techniques don't work
that well so you know core case is
driving on the highway when traffic is
moving smoothly and the weather is good
and the system is great at that you know
better than a person because it pays
more attention and you might think about
level four autonomous driving where it
helps you sort of like cruise control
that's all well and good but fully
trusting the system right the subtitle
of the book is about building AI that we
can trust fully trust in a system means
not just you know like cruise control
but you're always still paying attention
to be like I can actually read a book in
the back and before you could do that it
would have to deal with the periphery
cases too and so periphery is like there
aren't a lot of data recorded about tow
truck stopped on the side of the road
and you know you might gather you might
put a camera in a car for a million
hours and nuts or well for a hundred
thousand hours and not see that and so
he's the bizarre longtail so exactly
it's exactly about the bizarre long tail
so outliers or edge cases people have
different names I was using periphery
right now the outliers are these cases
in the long cattle which means there's
not that many of them right the fact
tale is there's many many cases of being
you know four meters behind you know
this kind of you know being behind you
tell Tesla or something like that
this is just so much data about that but
there's not a lot of data about what
happens when there are tow trucks and
these there's even less data about like
Electric skateboards in the streets of
Manhattan and so you want a system
that's flexible enough to deal with an
electric skateboard even if it wasn't in
the sample of data that's looking at you
could also think of this like in terms
of like politics and you do polls you
need a big sample the the in order to
cover all the possibilities with dumb
techniques they don't really understand
the world you need so much data in order
to get a representative enough sample
what people do is not that they have
that vast a database so that they have a
lot but they have reasoning techniques
kind of a knowledge about how the world
works so if some police officer comes by
with a hand lettered sign saying please
don't go here you're like well it's a
police officer and must have written it
on the sign because they didn't have
time it must be a recent emergency and
I'm gonna take his word for it or her
word for it and I'm gonna go around and
so you could reason about that where's
these systems we like they don't have
anything like that in the database sense
that they just drive right ahead or
whatever and so there's this infinite
range in driving of of cases that you
just haven't seen before that makes
driving really hard to solve with narrow
AI natural language is too even worse
like every sentence that you hear that's
interesting you never heard before sure
there ought to ask you about this with
IBM Watson seems to be like the big
issue that was scanning through all
these new medical papers and trying to
find some well it didn't cause it didn't
work right so so IBM Watson um I mean I
should be careful with us I get sued but
so IBM Watson
you know won at jeopardy and that was
very impressive but it turned out to be
a narrower job than we initially thought
so it looked like wow it's understanding
natural language but it turns out that
almost every answer in jeopardy is the
title of a Wikipedia page and so then
that means your job is not really to
understand the question it's just to
find which question or sorry which
Wikipedia page comes closest to the
question Wow and that turns out to be a
lot easier these ninety four and a half
percent or something one of the answers
are like that and if you combine that
with the speed of the computer hitting
the buzzer you know you're good to go
but it doesn't mean this system actually
understands things so then some of the
top brass at IBM not necessarily the
people working on Watson said well can
you make this do medicine and I think
some of the people working on Watson
we're like well that's actually a harder
problem they're like no you're gonna
make your student Madison and they kind
of scale back over the years from we're
gonna make it a doctors we're gonna make
we're gonna teach students to we're
gonna help with animal care or something
like that like they really back down and
you know the original idea was is gonna
do great medical diagnoses but even easy
cases that sometimes made mistakes on so
like it failed to diagnose heart attack
sometimes and it didn't really
understand the stuff that's working with
so they're all these tricks that you
might call text
but distinct from actually understanding
language so tax processing includes
things like keyword search so you can
see that you know this word often occurs
in this context and so you can guess
that it's a you know affiliated with
this thing but it doesn't like the same
thing as knowing that causal mechanism
knowing you know that that a failed you
know that the heart is a pump like if
you know that the heart is a pump thing
you can reason about what happens if the
pump doesn't work but if you don't
actually understand what a mechanical
pump is it's you don't really have a
concept of what the circulatory system
is about and Watson doesn't really
understand what a pump is and nor does
any other AI system really I mean
someone may have built a narrow AI
system for that there are simulations
for the heart but nobody has a general
system that can kind of read a biology
textbook and come away with the
conceptual underpinnings such that it
could use that information in different
ways the closest we have is a system now
that can do multiple choice questions
but it's still like using the
statistical things it's not that hard to
break my co-author just saw this new
system and a day later found an example
to break it is like something like a
certain Pig died last Tuesday and then
multiple-choice will it come back to
life next week the week after or never
and system like you know next week and
back to life are correlated and the
system's comes up with next week it
doesn't really understand what death is
and if you don't have the conceptual
underpinnings of death and you don't
really understand biology you gave a
couple other interesting ones like did
George Washington own a computer it's
like okay computer was invented you know
six 70 years or whatever ago you can
count on different ways with all the
ways that you can can't even go back to
Babbage or whatever but it was not there
were no computers in George Washington's
time and and people should know that and
should be able to figure out even though
there's no sand the point of that
example is a lot of things you can look
up a keyword search but you can't look
that one up or you couldn't before we
wrote this thing in The Times you
couldn't look up nobody had a sentence
George Washington was alive before
computers were invented if you a keyword
search then great you're done but if
nobody happened to have that sentence
then in order to answer the question was
george washington alive or did he have a
computer you have to understand he
couldn't have a computer if he was alive
before their computers
it's it's trivial for you know any
ordinary least adult human being
probably most kids by the system's don't
have a conceptual framework of life
death span of introduction of an
invention and so forth and so if it's
not on the keyword search they can't put
it together I'm really interested to see
where our global resources are going to
go for building this first principle
conceptual framework of general
intelligence as well as where we're
gonna put resources towards narrow
intelligences and I really appreciate
how you're pushing us to see things from
a first principle conceptual framework
just like the human is forms when
they're born I love that aspect of what
you're teaching I took a lot of
philosophy as an undergrad and I think
that you know that taught me to look at
the big picture and not just the thing
that you're pounding away on right now
and I think the field in general is kind
of pounding away with a tool that's
right there and there's money to be made
and you know it's not totally crazy
but it doesn't put the field as a whole
in the position to do the right thing to
solve the harder problem so if we really
want to solve medicine and have machines
integrate all of the stuff they read
machines have to be able to read and
that's like not on the agenda of what
you know Google and Facebook are
necessarily trying to do with if what
they're trying to do is sell ads I mean
it's some research in those companies
but you do if the goal is really the
long term you might set things up
differently yes one proposal I made was
to build something like CERN for AI we
could have a large multidisciplinary
multinational collaboration there are
problems with that idea so you want to
make sure that it doesn't just become a
bunch of academics finding funding for
their own particular research you have
to be coordinated with a goal and so
forth I think that's one possibility
another possibility that I'm following
right now as I built my own company I
can't take on all of this but we're
trying to take on some of this with
respect to robotics the company is
called robust AI and we're trying to go
after some of the harder problems that
we think other people are running away
from because their tools don't work and
we're trying to build a new set of tools
so it's you know also possible at least
in some circumstances to do it in a
corporate environment
now you started hinting at this a little
bit I love this idea of some sort of
like a global multidisciplinary effort
with the goal of building a general
intelligence how even just a system that
can read like you know forget yeah yeah
general tells but just like the other
agreed you know and of course there's an
interaction between the two but like our
forget the current computers are
illiterate like you know people are like
is AI gonna be here in ten years like if
I can't read like if you can't you know
read this unstructured part of Wikipedia
the stuff that's not in boxes then like
how are you gonna you know bootstrap
your system so then would you say we're
moving into this information technology
exponential technology age there's eight
billion of us the amount of
democratization of these powers is
happening across so many aspects of of
biotech neuro tech AI all these types of
things how do you foresee us
geopolitically harmonizing more is this
the process of like self work that we
need to go I'm not currently super
optimistic on that side so I mean one
codicil to what you just said is there
are ways in which AI is becoming more
democratic and less democratic so the
what's great is a lot of stuff is being
published openly some of it's being
patented and not everybody's talking
about that so places like Google do a
lot of patenting in the AI domain so
there's some questions there but the
bigger question is the techniques that
people are building are very
computationally expensive so you know
sometimes one simulation run and one of
these neural networks can cost a hundred
thousand dollars or a million dollars so
just because everybody and their brother
can watch a Coursera course and our
sister and watch a Coursera course and
learn how these techniques work doesn't
mean they can do it at scale and the
techniques don't necessarily work if
they're not at scale so one thing I
think a lot of corporations find out is
like what works for Google with the
massive amount of data that Google has
doesn't necessarily work for a smaller
company where there's not as much data
and so there's tensions both around like
the ability to they eat let me start
that sentence again there's
techniques that now anybody can use but
to use them well you need Google style
or Google scale compute and Google scale
data and not everybody has that
available now the techniques that the
human mind uses are not so driven by
data and you know your brain uses like
20 Watts not 20,000 watts so it is
possible in principle with the brain as
as existence proof to have AI techniques
that don't demand a lot of data that
don't demand enormous amount of compute
but those aren't the ones that are being
developed right now so the ones that are
being democratized are the ones that
Google and Facebook and Amazon so forth
are best position to use and not
necessarily ones that you at home can
use you know that well you might be able
to build something for your doorbell to
detect whether you know the UPS truck
has arrived there's some things that
even at home people can do but people at
home are not going to be using these
tools to build real natural language
understanding what has been your
connection with source or with the
divine and then how do you see our
connections with that higher power of
being relevant to our global harmony I
am NOT a divine power kind of guy I do
take a lot of inspiration from nature I
moved to the Pacific Northwest because I
just love the beauty of it all and and
so I mean I guess my connection is I'm
pretty amazed with what nature has come
up with and I like to surround myself
with with many of its products do you
think we're in a simulation I do not I
understand the arguments that people
like Elon Musk have given but again I
don't see any direct evidence for it do
you want to give me an argument for it
we're here to just feature how you feel
about it we've taken a lot of interest I
don't I don't see any direct evidence
for the hypothesis I guess another thing
I'll say is it's much harder to build
really good simulations then I think a
lot of people realize so you know it's
one thing to build a simulated
simulation like grand theft auto but to
build a really detailed simulation of
the world particularly human behavior
is really really hard and nobody really
knows how to do that they're also more
mundane things like we don't really know
how to simulate liquids that well and I
mean you could imagine need tell some
science fiction story about how the year
is actually you know twenty thousand two
hundred and and you're just toying with
me right now and the brain and of that
kind of style and you know you've
decided to immerse me in this
environment and in which the simulation
tools themselves are lousy in order to
make the whole thing I mean you can make
up a story but if you were talking about
certainly the technology that is
available today it's not good enough to
make simulations that have the richness
of the real world so like you can look
YouTube for like physics engine fails
and you'll find things like a car that's
sitting here on the side of the road and
then it just starts jumping up and down
for no reason because there's like some
instability in the simulator and we
don't see that stuff in the real world
so you know it would have to be a very
elaborate story to make sense of the
facts and then now more coincidences
that you rest on the lower the
probability is you know it's not zero
but it's not you know it's not the best
explanation of the data I have in front
of me what would you say is an the most
important skill for young kids like your
children as well as the adults as we go
into this exponential technology age to
learn
I mean first I would say that not
everything is exponential so the ability
of machines to read has not grown
exponentially it's grown hardly at all
in 50 years so not everything is
exponential but I'll presume for the
sake of argument that Moore's law
Carlson curve stone yeah I mean so a lot
of stuff follows that but general
intelligence hasn't rate so there's not
actually been growth in general
intelligence so one thing to say is that
if general intelligence isn't rising
that fast but narrow intelligence is
then it's not a good way to make your
living doing a narrow intelligence
because it's going to be replaced so you
don't want to be the guy scooping ice
cream cone
because machines gonna be doing that
pretty soon but creativity is gonna be
valued for a long time because machines
are not really that good at it and for
the moment machines are not that good at
careful reading of things and so
learning to read well may distinguish us
from machines for quite some time the
last people to be replaced will be
entertainers because we will like the
fact that they are a human being so you
know kids growing up to be entertainers
is you know an interesting possibility
I think scientists are going to be
around for a while not forever you know
if I really do my job with AI scientists
will get replaced sooner but I think the
problems are hard enough that they won't
get replaced immediately if you take a
long perspective like ten thousand years
from now I don't think it'll be many
jobs if you have a different kind of
economy where people have to derive
their value from their creative pursuits
and not from their work no not from Kate
work just not gonna be that many paid
jobs ten thousand years from now then
you could just you can extrapolate or
whatever interpolated in between and
maybe 30 years from now there'll be
fewer paid jobs than there are now and
you know a thousand years fewer still we
just not going to be able to have a
society that is organized around finding
meaning from paid work because it just
won't be enough yeah even the
permutation potential for creativity for
computation is just ten thousand years
from now it just feels like what
creative output could still even be left
that's undiscovered how about what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
I'm saying nature in all of its forms
the way way that species are so
exquisitely adapted for their niches and
the way in which the systems that are
built they're not always perfect but
they're you know often sort of from an
engineering standpoint pretty
spectacular and you know we're just
catching up to nature and some things
and not others right
I mean AI is of case where we have not
caught up
entirely with nature we've caught up in
little corners of it right so we can
build AI systems that play go better
than people but in terms of general
intelligence which is part of nature we
still have not caught up whoa
this has been super fun Gary I really
appreciate you coming on our show and
talking to us thank you thank you very
much thank you so much everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking
also to have more conversations to your
friends families co-workers people
online about rebooting AI about building
a new conceptual framework for
time-space causality versus a narrow
intelligences have more conversations
about it and get building more everyone
also do check out the links in the bio
below check out the link Gary Marcus
comm also robust dot a I his Twitter
Provos LinkedIn profile in the book
rebooting AI as well as down there
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organization's the leaders around
the world that you believe and support
them help them grow support simulation
our links are below to our PayPal
cryptocurrency
patreon and design cool merch if you pay
all stuffs below Thank You orisha PR our
co-producer for cutting SEPA so to
greatly appreciate it and go and build
the future everyone to manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thanks for tuning in and we'll see
you soon